we waited 45 minutes to get inside all
right let's hope it was worth it
you think so I hope so I'm crying a bit
here holy cow
[Music]
we're gonna go get some lunch at the
best poutine place here in Montreal
Haim is not gonna have 15 maybe he'll
try it
no not gonna try it all right supposed
to be the best poutine in the world best
poutine in the world we did the smoked
meat we had both bagels we had the
Dragon's beard last step is the best
poutine in the world let's go
[Music]
there's a big lineup to get out you just
gonna stand in line and we're gonna look
for parking because this lineup is out
the door crazy I Nina we love you we
found parking it's a little far away
yeah we split up our tasks Lina is
getting in line hopefully is at the
front just as we get there and I'm ready
to have some poutine at the world-famous
I forget the name but they're
world-famous you're gonna have something
else all right that's okay
anyone have something else just do
french fries with a little bit of with
cheese and some gravy
we'll say listen we don't want poteen
but we want the french fries with some
gravy and cheese
okay let's see where she's at
here's the lineup this is the lineup
this is the place she move up let's go
find her
where is Nina there she is did you move
up a little bit alright you look cold
you're excited what to get inside to get
home home to what Toronto or home to our
you want to see Timo you Swan the lie
down just wanna relax you wanted
something else all right mystery
activity with Nina
[Music]
okay ones with the heart the classic the
Maddy bacon green peppers mushroom and
onions the subway yard bacon onions
Swiss cheese and sour cream
the festival ground beef Swiss cheese
hot peppers and green eyes well what are
you gonna have it's spicy a top peppers
oh this is this is tricky too many
options
I want the sour cream we're going
several yards making onion Swiss cheese
a sack cream final final answer Payton
did as he was told and got ordered juice
right
you ordered juice chocolate milk and
vegetables right what you are spoiled on
this trip spoiled
it's called vacation for a reason that's
okay Nina and I are eating a bunch of
junk - I'm gonna get healthy there look
all I'm having is some nice water
get me water happy vacation
oh he's got his Chuck of milk Nina got
her four years out comiste walk this
Reilly yet it's a dark beer all right
how is it you like it
No
we waited 45 minutes to get inside
all right let's hope it was worth it you
think so I hope so
residency behind me pretty pretty busy
place still packed open 24 hours a day
when you are the batch there's always
the quality always packed havens got
some kids stuff to play with
oh it's not even he's gonna do his own
thing forget what they give you do your
own thing I like to listen he's a
Carmichael that's what happens we do her
own thing let's see what you draw Nina's
drawn to Nina's just writing her name
Nina
painting the artists just gonna spray
that crazy
[Music]
what's that a masterpiece you're gonna
make a masterpiece
all right don't distract you the
masterpiece is done hold it up let's see
oh excuse me
thanks guy can only see upside down you
want it to flip it around so I can see
oh he's got an autograph his work first
it's gotta sign it all right all right
all right this is it the masterpiece bun
tree oh that's good what's the thing on
the side paint in and then let your
signature that's really good all right
that's the signature I like it Lina I
think it's the longest we've waited for
food maybe ever
in line that we ever stood in line that
long no all right let's see if it's
worth it hopefully it's coming soon
angry face what's your hungry face
that's a hungry face what's that what's
that oh my god I'm so full taste don't
we don't want that face what's that man
I'm ready to sleep face
what's the I'm so happy is the best day
of my life face yeah okay let's end on
that oh I see a burger and onion rings
this is I hey look at that look at that
look at that
[Music]
they're real good thumbs up
was it worth the wait Nina maybe okay go
yummy thumbs up
alright nice I'm about to halfway mark
still feeling good Nina how you doing
still going solid getting little pull
Cain is also felt halfway mark okay
let's go finish up finish up yummy
still get the thumbs up all right
finished
yeah just have this got to finish the
beer and that's it cut the bell and go
home
the lineup is even longer we made it out
how we feeling Oh
allergies are kicking in a bit had a
sneeze attack there I'm saved you guys
from that I'm crying a bit here holy cow
we made it high five everybody hands in
and two three team we're gonna go get
we're gonna go home and go walk team Oh
[Music]
do tema hello mr. fun aspires okay you
guys gonna take him out
grunty my cousins at your home well the
candy after candy after you take him out
have fun
hello blue nation walking with a day
three realize you didn't update you guys
from last night we just passed out so we
heard it through last night we relaxed
we ate we watched Pompeii not not the
greatest movie you know thought Pompeii
would be a happy ending it's about a
volcano that destroys everybody in this
week well at least the happy ending is
that we don't live in Pompeii as you can
see it's snowing here in Montreal first
day of snow Timo is not enjoying the
snow we got to go brush up the car and
then go home much that was fun and get
some coffee get some hot chocolate for
Timo what is Haven get hot water juice
hi Kathleen okay let's go get the car
good morning good morning it's great to
stay up late good morning good morning
to you and you and you and in the
morning in the morning
[Music]
yeah is that it something like that
we're kind of spazzy in the morning of a
Sunday no cover girls don't have lazy
Sundays caracals crushed
Biman ciao
[Music]
okay first stop Tim horns let's get some
breakfast in some cafe what's happening
is that my coffee yeah love it all right
Ian is back what did we get Nina the
food we got a team on the lap he's very
excited grilled cheese for Hayden okay
you're gonna go back in anything that's
going back in I got my sausage and egg
and hash brown crap how is it
thumbs up for Hayden's oh you're gonna
go to the washroom very soon
[Music]
okay
pitstop time we are how we doing good we
are about two hours just under two hours
away from home if we're gonna do a pit
stop get some food get some gas do some
relieving and then get back in the car
and John Paul look at Nina with her
sunglasses hello I'm squinting who
battle Wow
all right let's go in let's go in please
Nina Timo where is she huh
Bree she first Lina all right we are one
hour and 26 minutes oh wait time to get
going on the road to Toronto all right
so we made it back
hey guys human feeling good how was
Montreal best Holly from the chip was
what what was the highlight
favorite part smell meat smoked meat
drags me yeah dragons pick dragon spear
candy was pretty good smokes me smoke me
for Nina she mo it was a highlight he
was chasing after the cat yeah he was
chasing cats I didn't get it on video I
tried but in the video highlight for me
he's spending time with you guys so is
good lime in bed watching how to train a
dragon cartoons with Hayden spending
time with Nina watching her eat lots of
yummy new food and we made it back drive
back not so bad pretty quick not that
many stops once the only one stop that
was a good long weekend we left on
Thursday night when we come back onto
Sunday so that's it hope you guys have a
fantastic weekend thank you for joining
us for ours we believe in you hope we
continue to believe in yourselves and
whatever I was he soon
[Music]